hello reject nation Greg here Kalyn
Nicole Foster from big screen books data
myself I said that the extreme books is
her YouTube channel people it's a great
channel trailer reactions on their movie
reviews on their as well as you know a
lot of coverage about certain novels and
whatnot yeah go check it out guy stuff
great great channel glad to have you
here she drove all the way down from San
Diego just to be here no other plans and
we were talking beforehand how there's
probably gonna be new infinity war
trailer coming out soon specially
because they changed the release date
and I got sent over a few articles about
some new a fitting 50t war photos so you
made sure to change her shirts she has
her Spidey shirt and I have all the
Marvel you do a paintball Caitlin Nicole
Foster let's let's look at some of these
bad boys alright so first one on the
agenda is look at really upgrades like
we laster's what is this suit it's
called the bleeding edge armor okay and
among its many new capabilities are
rocket thrusters that jut out from Tony
Stark's arms and back allowing him to
propel himself into deep space whoa
well if he's building that suit that
kind of gives you a hint is some
potential action sequences that we might
get some space yeah because we do see in
the trailer that there's gonna be some
sequences are in space specially with
Thor guards the galaxies with Thanos
going around the world and whatnot but
we use this thing though them in space
guardians 20 star Tony opening the space
thinks he has a chance
that's pretty cool though that he's able
to build something like that where he
can go into space like that I wonder how
that suit will actually translate not to
the big screen it looks cool a little a
little corny at the same time but still
I mean I'm sure when I actually plays it
on the big screen it's gonna be sweet as
anytime Tony has a new new upgrade it's
always like Oh Iron Man - what he put
the his chest and it forms around his
body enough or even the Hulkbuster suit
when he had that and on this one it's
cool he's they're introducing a new suit
right here sweetie probably want me to
go into space so he can take on
supernatural characters like no problem
and here's like a big one everyone's
talking about the iron spider one here
where you can see that he has like
spider legs down the back I'm not that
familiar with this one though with this
suit in the comics supposedly that Iron
Man does give him a suit along the lines
of this and it's things like this why
I'm happy that Spidey's in the MCU yeah
because they're taking advantage of well
how we can reinvent Spider Man is really
making a part of the MCU and that's how
you get a different renditions and this
is what I love right now I like to see
I'm excited to see this those legs cuz
also kind of look ridiculous but I don't
know they could be effective lumens of
research the new Spider limbs he can
glide easier you can store stuff there's
cameras so you can see better yeah yeah
the bottom line it just it just looks
freakin sweet it does yeah like we're
selling iron spider suit that was
already cool they have they're really
amping up the technology and it's cool
that both Tony Stark and Peter Holland
upgraded extent extensions on their
suits yeah it is a spider like yeah it
could be like just the look that they're
going for and that's an awesome thing
here's like here's the big one that a
lot of people I heard I saw a title for
this and I was like what the hell Thanos
is throwing a moon in this photo how do
you defeat that stop everyone
it's gonna come in handy
what do you do with the mad that you
feel if you're Santos you use the purple
and blue infinity stones to rid of the
moon out of orbit and hurl it against
the ground like a dinner plate Wow Wow
you know he goes around other places too
so this might not be earth but that is
here looks like it's probably the suite
yeah I mean there's some cool stuff here
the fan I was throwing the moon the new
iron spider suit having extensions on it
Tony Stark's extension see this is
really exciting stuff because more than
just collabing them together they're
still expanding and building upon their
powers and whatnot so opening up the
universe excited for this man most
anticipated movie of the year
hands down and don't forget guys they
changed the release date it's less
important to get a new trailer out is
who
possible because there's because there's
a release date that's been changed I
need to put that into put like an
official changed in your face because
there's only one trailer out and it's me
you got to change that guys you got to
change that well alright man I'm so
excited for this movie
nervous I'm nervous because I'm like
what if this is the one Rotten Tomatoes
convoluted too many carriers I don't
know man I'm comfort umpire I feel like
I don't think it will be but if it
happens to be one of the weaker ones
I'll be like it doesn't matter it's
still like setting up the next kind of
you know infinity it's one of those
things work no matter what I'm gonna
enjoy out of it like no matter just
seeing everyone together like is making
these snow houses just a picture makes
me like the movie I've already told
myself I like this movie alright guys
well make sure to let us know both of us
know when that infinity war trailer is
out cuz it's gonna be an anxiety attack
to get that video up as soon as possible
you guys can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification Bell
check us on patreon full-length TV show
reactions over there as well as weekly
Q&A where we do full video responses to
each individual question we don't breeze
through them but most importantly check
out Caitlin Nicole Foster on big screen
books awesome YouTube channel link in
the description box do it now or else
you are not loved remember those words I
will love you